how will I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in the theme of the debate is to
take a look at selfie culture there's
been a lot of dialogue and discourse
around our obsessions with the selfie
and why have we become so sort of
focused on ourselves and so determined
to document and report every last aspect
of our daily existence to discuss this
fascinating and very relevant subject
today we have the amazing Helen lettera
who some of you may know from her
appearances on BBC's absolutely fabulous
then we have shahida bari academic and
broadcaster you can hear her often on
the radio presenting front row and free
thinking on my left we have Steve Taylor
a professor of psychology no less at
Leeds University who will hopefully be
able to offer a slightly more spiritual
take on the on the cult of the selfie
and fire is finally but not many
millions last Suzanne b'bye I think I
got that right who is an art historian
and curator specializing in the art of
Iran and Islam so starting with Helen
narcissism or self obsession is it an
effective life strategy good I'm glad to
go first
so um narcissism and I'm sure the panel
will know more about the detail of
narcissism but I my understanding is
that it is actually quite literally a
condition that may be less common than
the Millennials who are attracted to
self-expression in what is the
conventional norm of our society by
replicating themselves in various ways
like we've moved on from posing in front
of the Eiffel Tower of course we do
hundreds and hundreds of photographs
can take so narcissism I think probably
serves great artists in that they are
free from comparing themselves to limits
again I'm not an expert but Picasso
charismatic leaders I don't know about
if Trump isn't here businessman I don't
know but you know narcissism serves
certain people and we would be a lesser
off if we didn't have great works of art
from genius people who are able to be to
think that they are they really are the
most interesting person in the world
which I find rather amusing I think
that's really funny because it's like a
genuine belief so there's no doubt and I
think in society what is useful for us
to function in a socialized way is to
have the ability to have humility to
have some kind of self doubt and when
Tony Blair you could say as a current
was a charismatic leader so I think it
serves us I was we were talking in the
green room thinking what we can say and
and I I remember an audition kind of
thing in America where if you if you are
modest as my upbringing is I was brought
up to be polite and not boast showing
off boasting is a problem I played
myself down in a way that I thought was
appealing and of course I didn't get the
job because we are all car salesmen at
some level we can't avoid that and we
have to sell our wares and there's
nothing dirty about it preening is bad
self belief is essential narcissism is
repellent so I think I probably sit in
the middle of all those things in order
to be a kiss' tically driving myself
forward my present my only very small
presence on to it I don't really
understand it but I kind of do it
because if I didn't do it I wouldn't be
serving my better good fantastic thank
you very much
round of applause feel better good
shahida i was going to talk about the
Kylie Simon song I think we should have
come in with you're so vain playing in
the background right but the thing about
that song nothing about that song if
you've ever listened to the lyrics is
that she rhymes apricots with Givat
apricots Givat and yachts which for me
the first time in history that I mean
this language that anybody's ever done
worse and I I'm making fun of it because
I'm trying to point out that there's
something more interesting in that song
and I would suggest to you that there's
something much more interesting in the
idea of narcissism and we might start to
talk quite technically about
distinguishing between vanity narcissism
and self-consciousness I don't
necessarily think that's productive what
I want to say to you as a philosopher is
that it seems to me that narcissism is
only a version it's a version of the
self-consciousness that philosophy has
directed to us for centuries and it's
not always about appearance it seems to
me tarsus ism although to my eye I've
just written the book about dress about
the philosophy of dress and actually
appearance is to me infinitely
interesting and complex and in fact I'm
looking out at you and you look like
infinitely interesting and complex and
alluring people to me so it's not just
about appearance and appearance is
important for me narcissism or
self-consciousness is also about how you
care for the self care for the self and
it's about acts of self engagement that
can be thoughtful they can be ironic
they can be knowing they can be profound
and I've got two main points really that
I want to just cover very quickly and
I'll try and talk about it more in
conversation with you guys one is that
seeing yourself and attending to
yourself is a really important and
complicated philosophical strategy so
narcissism we think is this process by
which we watch ourselves and often we
think that we were vigilant to be self
regulate and we assess and measure our
appearance in the world not only against
ideals of beauty and propriety should
you wear well is in this weather
etcetera etcetera but also in
relationship to age I think more and
more I'm gonna turn 38 on Monday if you
see me say happy
birthday but reflecting on our
appearance is one way that we are forced
to confront our every day attrition the
fact that we're dying every given moment
at any minute right Heidegger says at
every moment at and at any instant we
are dying and were compelled to
acknowledge our mortality when we see
our bodies where we see our bodies as is
mutable things that are not within the
limits of our control and that is
absolute agony for someone about 7:38
but it is also it's also a vulnerability
it's a vulnerability that we share with
others and as soon as we start to extend
our imagination to the possibility of
other people having the same thoughts
and self-consciousness is us then we
form the basis of an ethical
relationship and so when you look in the
mirror and you lament your fluctuating
weight or your thinning hair I'm not
looking at anyone in particular or your
tired skin the kindness that we cannot
permit ourselves in those moments when
you might extend more sympathetically to
others with the understanding of our own
imperfections so to my mind
self-consciousness that comes of a side
kind of narcissism is a really important
strategy for thinking about other people
and it's a philosophical strategy the
second thing I want to say is that we
live we're very used to we're accustomed
to this idea of a kind of contract based
culture of modern rights and
responsibilities whereby we reciprocally
abide by laws and regulations and I
think there's another way to think about
how that version of civic society is not
just predicated on a contract it's
predicated on ideas of self cultivation
and that's not far removed from
narcissism and what I mean by that is
something the Greeks talk about they
talk about caring for the self and that
the philosopher one of the philosophers
I love most of all takes up that
challenge in the 20th century that's
Michel Foucault that the French
philosopher who is ravaged by HIV by it
he dies of an AIDS related illness in
the 80s and his his body is pitilessly
ravaged by illness although he carries
all my
these amazing leather jackets and really
cool bottle top glasses but he says
self-care can take so many different
forms
he says writing reading eating
exercising but also training oneself to
be a citizen being committed to a
community to take care of oneself is to
attend with great concern to every
aspect of one's being taking pains with
one's holding and with one's health
alike and that seems to be such a
powerful way to be in the world and so
that's sort of what I want to end with
this idea that we have to it's really
important to be able to see ourselves
both literally and metaphorically and we
have to find some way of holding a
mirror up to ourselves to hold ourselves
up for inspection and that is the work
of philosophy moving on Steve well I
would agree that um self-care is
important but I think narcissism is a
kind of distortion of self care is a
kind of like an extreme version of self
care where the self becomes too
important get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in dog